hello welcome back to new rockstars
debrief I'm Erik Bosse joining me today
are Sam basher how do we Howe and Maude
Garrett what's up guys this is it we're
we're locking in our final predictions
for a ventures in game or one week away
we're also gonna talk about Star Wars
Knights of the Old Republic the Dark
Phoenix trailer that came out this week
and a rumor about a fourth Thor movie in
the works Hammerstein Chanukah and here
is your friendly weekly reminder that
this show is also available as a podcast
you can find us on Apple podcasts the
MLA app or wherever you get your podcast
and you know don't forget to subscribe
to the Westeros weekly feed if you're a
game of Thrones fan and from Oracle fans
we just got a new feed just for you guys
it's called inside Marvel and it's gonna
be where you'll be able to find all the
audio versions advanced access of all of
our Marvel content on this channel so
you know we're covering all bases and on
that podcast feed you'll also find
ticket instructions for our big end game
watch party event in LA next week your
ticket if you choose to go we'll get you
a free soda and a popcorn at the El
Capitan Theatre which is probably the
coolest way to watch of interest in game
Disney goes all out for these things and
there's also gonna be catered appetizers
after the movie plus you'll get to see
Avengers in game as I said the best
place but it's you'll be able to see if
you go to the 2:30 screening of it
you'll be in the audience for a live
episode of this show North Stars debrief
we're gonna be there we're gonna talk
about Avengers in game and get your
thoughts we're gonna break it down
together and the link will also be in
the description if you're watching this
on youtube and in the show notes if
you're experiencing this through podcast
of this episode and tickets are selling
fast so definitely hop on it we've never
done something like this okay like a
debrief straight after the movie yes
it's a true debrief that's true like
let's talk about what just experienced
soldier in debriefing on this okay let's
get started with our top story
Avengers in game we're in the endgame
now folks we just really talked about
the fact that this is like the last time
that we are going to go in blind with it
there's a loss and we don't know
anything yeah that's cool
I've been very lucky that I have not
seen any less boilers or anything like
that and I would like to keep it that
way I've been knowing my spoilers yeah
this week we don't have inside access to
anything some of us are gonna be
seen it earlier next week but like we
don't pay attention to leaks or anything
like that's like cheating right so if
like you've been unlucky to see like a
screencap or like footage that looks
like potato e in a leak we don't want to
see it don't share with us right because
it's too close to the movie to break
that stuff down then we're just spoiling
the movie at that you are trash goblins
if you do that yes and you'll get the
media block for me if you ever do that
permanent I will never unblock you know
okay so anyway let's talk about endgame
set some final predictions right let's
put our final bets in for what we think
this will go based off of our
speculation from trailers are
imaginative wishful thinking for what we
want the story to be and you know this
time next week and alga v10 we'll know
for sure so be well know exactly how the
infinity saga ends but let's talk about
it here
what this movie will be what phase four
will look like we're gonna run through
our wildest theories that we've had and
heard over the past five past year
there's been a lot of interesting ones
along with our current and final
predictions so there can be one place in
an all in one place and next week we'll
check back in and see how we did and
spoiler alert we haven't seen the movie
yet but you know sometimes her theories
end up being right just analyzing things
a bit too closely okay let's talk about
Doctor Strange from infinity war he had
some cryptic lines he saw fourteen
million six hundred five different
futures he said that surrendering the
time stone letting thanasis win was
quote the only way he said we're in the
endgame now providing the title for the
for the next movie and we've theorized
lots of stuff about dr. strange one of
the theories we said that maybe he put
them all in a big time loop before he
died like he did with Dormammu to get a
second shot at take him down another
maybe that he projected the time stone
into the future so that he could help
the future Avengers use that time stone
to defeat Thanos and another one is that
since Doctor Strange and the ancient one
understand the quantum realm better than
other characters do since they have a
vast knowledge of the multiverse maybe
dr. Strange's knowledge of the quantum
realm where Scott Lang is currently
still trapped will be used to meddle
with timelines in some way so I'm
curious to know from you guys how
important do you think Doctor Strange
will be to the plot of endgame and how
much should we have looked into him over
this basket honestly I didn't
about that theory that he sent the time
stone to the future and brought it back
just in time to give it to Thanos like
that's pretty dope
I mean it's you getting the time-travel
gobbledygook a little bit when you know
that you're like mm but what was in the
future how long was in the future and
also Thanos has it in the present so
where was it times relevant it's a
circle it's wibbly-wobbly you know it it
could be anything you could the writers
can make it mean whatever they want it
to mean but the same time it's like the
biggest threat to fennel really and that
line of dialogue stood out to me so much
it's the only way we said that because
he's tried everything in this is it
didn't he had to sacrifice himself
knowing that he would that he would
sacrifice his cape to the K yeah the
cloaca levitate yeah it's weird that he
said the only one cuz it was like
weirdly helpful or and hopeful in a way
like oh so this is the only way so we're
on the right track no no it was defeated
for sure he's tried everything and this
was the only way and it's not great when
you only have one shot a lot of it means
that like most people will die which
we've seen so this isn't pretty but
Doctor Strange is 100% the key to all of
this I think that's a good way to think
about it and I guess I'm curious will
the gimmick or the strategy that the
Avengers end up using an endgame do you
think it'll be
what Doctor Strange prescribed or will
it be like they use so knowledge or do
you think they'll use some of his
knowledge but then crack some new code
that is unrelated because he's already
seen it how many did Doctor Strange
watched the ant-man theory in that whole
scheme of comments down below that was
13 million of them and then he did
another million of different objects yes
there's some when you guys commented on
one of our videos 10 likes not fair
Doctor Strange saw in game 14 million 65
yeah we assume the version of the plot
of endgame is what Doctor Strange were
saw and I suggest that you guys go back
and watch all of our videos on there
because we've speculated all different
kinds of specific conditions that needed
to be in place for this to be the only
way forward things ranging from Tony
Stark's success successfully punching
thinness in the face and drawing blood
how important would that have been is an
important that Tony Stark
kind of like in 300 how we make Xerxes
bleed and
like oh no I did miss like that was
important symbolically to show the other
Spartan said he this God can bleed very
cool I I did watched
infinity war last night because I have
been working my way through it over like
the past week and it's still real good
gang honestly I would like to see some
things but I honest I would not see dr.
strange globe but I would like to see
something like some ramifications of him
being like no I knew this was gonna
happen I however you want to paint that
in a way that's not annoying or
condescending or what-have-you I'm on
board with that
yeah well moving on just to another
point we haven't really seen whatever
the new strategy will be in the second
half of endgame in any of the trailers
they've been pretty good about keeping
that stuff out really it looks like a
lot of footage has been from the first
half and one of the theories that we've
speculated is that things will get worse
for the Avengers before they get better
that there may be some kind of doomed
revenge mission in the opening act we
saw that in that release scene on Good
Morning America that they plan on just
going to take another swing at Thanos
now that they have Captain Marvel but if
that happens in the first act that can't
be the thing that defeats him right so
we've talked about maybe there could be
an early death of a major Avenger or
maybe even a second snap or some other
kind of great tragic thing that Thanos
does on them in the first part of the
movie the reason why I don't think
there's a second snap is because we've
never actually seen what the Infinity
Gauntlet can do with all the stones in
it so we've just seen him do one thing I
think we're gonna explore just how
formidable all the stones together are
gonna be alright it had that one blast
towards Stormbreaker but it didn't
really work and the directors have said
it's because he was still testing it out
yeah so like technically the gauntlet is
still supposed to be more powerful than
storm breakers but we haven't really
seen that other than the snap the day
though I think you're messing with
Thanos is still mortal and go back to
your comment we are dealing with gods in
this world and I think that gods can't
really die I mean I don't necessarily
think that Odin's dead per se I mean it
gods don't necessarily die they just go
off to oh like in Ragnarok supposed to
be a cyclical cycle it's not a possible
cycle yes exactly
hey got a couple redundancies built into
Ragnarok moving the title and yeah they
meant to come back in some way at least
in Norse mythology and sometimes in
Marvel Comics because everyone comes no
deaths a revolving door and isn't it
interesting that the way ode and died
ragnarok was like turning into particles
or eat it off yeah and to grow other
Odin's elsewhere so is there any
connection with that with the aesthetic
that we saw the other characters fade
away and is there any connection there
are they in the same whatever new place
they go to or they all they're hanging
out it's interesting I also like the
idea that in the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline that the story is based off of
nebula is basically being tortured over
and over and over again by Thanos I need
to see more of that we don't but during
that
and while Thanos is doing his evil guy
laughs hang out with Mephisto slapping
Captain America around nebulous sneaks
over and when Thanos gets defeated takes
the Infinity Gauntlet and uses it and I
like the idea of someone in like
basically she's been brutally abused by
this person and having the idea that
just a second her father and and maybe
trying to make the decision of what if
we got rid of Thanos and it's like well
you can't you can't just do that because
he is the result of everything that's
happened so far and doing that might
bring people back or it might make
everything way worse so I like the idea
of also maybe having nebula in a
position of like that she can make she
feels like she can have her hero moment
but really this is gonna backfire in a
big way and maybe we have our characters
have to talk her down cuz it could be
the end of her kind of redemption arc
because she is a villain she has
murdered a lot of people she is
dangerous but also the same time she
wants to be loved
she wants her sister back and she
doesn't want her father to ever hurt
someone it's like the stolid moment
where it's like emotion makes you do
yeah kind of a selfish move I suppose
the one that's for the greater good yeah
I think that's an interesting idea guys
like one of the Avengers could become in
a way a more selfish villain than even
Thanos was i I just did like a rewatched
of infinity war and I kind of made like
for the K for the sake of argument a
case that Thor is a structural villain
if Danis is the protagonist that Thor's
the antagonist so just for the sake of
even though I know he's a good guy yeah
like what if Thor since he's so pissed
off that his brother got killed that way
and he feels like it was a real personal
loss for him what if he gets his hand on
the gauntlet and just does things a
little worse than like no Thor won't
want to see angry Hemsworth for sure oh
yeah for sure that's definitely what I'm
all about but also I think one of the
best lessons we learned from infinity
war is even at their most powerful
they're not strong stronger than when
they're
together agree and like you even have
Thor getting a hammer back even though
the lesson we literally just learned is
that he doesn't need the hammer being
Thor is himself the sower was hidden
inside of us the whole time that's the
great lesson you learn and then even
with a hammer it doesn't matter Dano
still wins and sew them together having
to solve the Thanos problem also
probably is the answer for how to use
the Infinity stones in a way that makes
sense they're wishing stones their
different kind of Care Bear magic you
just you hold hands everyone holds a
stone they swallow it do whatever you
need to do and then they wish their
thing back so like Thor wishes back
Asgard and they bring back those gods or
the Valkyries or Loki or whatever you
want to do he's got a TV show coming up
you probably need them to be alive and
then like you have Tony Stark wishing
that the back or you have Captain
America wishing to go back to the forty
whatever a couple different options for
where you could go but the idea of them
having to be together to make that kind
of decision I think is how this movies
going to end because that's a lot well
let's talk about the Hulk
Emily's thrown out a couple big theories
about the Hulk a lot of you guys were
curious about the Hulk in infinity war
because he had that performance anxiety
he lost to Thanos in the opening minutes
and the Hulk is never supposed to lose
he's supposed to just beat someone to a
draw because he's angry or matter so one
theory that we've speculated about is
that maybe this is just part of his
evolution over the course the MCU that
maybe this could lead to a new
incarnation of the Hulk and endgame like
the professor Hulk version or some
version of that
where the Hulk is still in his whole
form but he has Bruce banners
intelligence and maybe the shredded but
another theory and this is the crazier
one that was like one of my favorite
ones to talk about on the channel is
that Hulk is not actually Hulk in this
movie that may be the reason why Hulk
lost and maybe the reason why Bruce
Banner when he comes back and his form
understand remembers things from when
Hulk was at the reins is that it's
actually Loki in disguise that Loki
maybe faked his death and projected
himself went they Anna snapped his neck
and then masqueraded as the Hulk and
Bruce Banner as he has been known who
masqueraded as Captain America in the
dark world and ODIs and Odin for a
couple years right so maybe the whole
version of this character that we've
seen throughout infinity war is actually
Loki what do you guys think on that
and I have some thoughts quick that
wants Loki he's actually really Matt
Damon well how's that how's that
character did he die on the ship because
that he did die actor on Asgard I don't
like this theory also because you see
him actively trying to become the Hulk
when no one else is around so why would
Loki do that there's no one there to
verify that he tried to do I know he's
in like an Iron Man suit and you could
like write your way around to like why
he would do that but I mean I you can't
put it past Loki he is a survivalist he
will do anything that he can to stay
alive betray anyone do anything we
thought he'd changed his way but you
know I don't I don't think he would have
gone that quickly who knows but at the
same time I really like the idea of
Professor Hulk I want it now please
classes labcoat very much how big do you
think those glasses have to be like yeah
what am i doing with my hands you think
no Sam I learnt the hard way yeah I hope
they have big plans for Hulk in this
movie and beyond in game because seeing
Hulk with Thor in Thor Ragnarok was such
an amazing pairing and I want to see
more in that direction whether it's the
cocky gladiator version of the character
or a more a character who has the
personality and yeah that's interesting
because they've spoiled I kind of had to
they spoiled Hulk in Ragnarok as soon as
they announced the movie basically like
hey don't worry it's not just a Thor
movie you're getting another Avenger as
well I know you and then in infinity war
they lied it was like no hoax at the end
don't worry he's gonna be more Conda
that's not true so now they've like
totally hit it I think he's gonna get a
really cool moment glasses lab kotas and
all he's gonna be looking sharp and
maybe he's gonna be able to talk as well
I don't know I I there-there's a fun
break then I saw where it was like Hulk
is Hulk banners banner the idea of them
together is kind of like doing
disservice to both of them cuz they're
both two different identities but also
the idea of finding harmony within
yourself and the different sides of your
own personality like there's something
sweet about that so that could be
something that's nestled into this
three-hour epic so who knows yeah well
we were talking about Loki as one of the
Fallen characters the tagline in this
movie is avenge the Fallen so let's talk
about there are other fallen characters
which of them do you think will come
act and will there be a difference
between the Fallen who dust it at the
end of the movie and the other ones like
Loki and Gamora Heimdall envision who
died in other ways we predicted that
Loki could resurrect at some point some
theories that were out there saying that
maybe he's banished to hell that I'm in
the realm that uh that hello was in and
he could come back the same way maybe
that's where gods go when they die or
another theory is that vision might
still be present in some way maybe
downloaded in his Cherie server or
trapped in a mine stone the way that
Gamora was trapped in the soul stone and
that maybe lots of characters could be
in different Infinity stones as these
kind of ghostly presences so how do you
guys think do we are we gonna see all
the characters who died in infinity were
gonna come back and maybe trade lives
for some of the living characters or do
you think there's gonna be some other
way that they get brought back quick
thing that I thought would have been
kind of cool just thinking about it
today we see Red Skull spoilers for that
movie we see Red Skull like show up and
he's like a guide for Thanos because he
messed with the Infinity stone it would
have been really cool if we saw like
Malekith who was if you guys forget Thor
the dark world he played with the
redstone and maybe like Ronan who played
with the Power Stone purple one like
coming back and being guides as well
like oh these are all people who tried
to use these and it backfired bad like
we like red school it was like
definitive like oh he could be somewhere
else
those two exploded or were crushed by
ships or whatever like I thought that
would be kind of fun as a fun theory out
of all those vision because I'm a big
vision supporter 2020 but like all right
because you need glasses huh I see
because I'm blind I would I like the
idea of vision being downloaded it's
like a newer body like you see a hint of
like that like the white like outline of
him when he gets the stone ripped out of
his head that look though I think is
really cool so that could be back in his
sweater come on I want the sweater he
pulled it off also he made it with his
skin we know some characters are gonna
have to come back because we've seen a
trailer with Peter Parker and Nick Fury
and Maria Hill in it for spider-man far
from home so I just hope that however
they bring them back is harder to
accomplish than it was for Thanos to
erase them okay so you know how at the
end of Harry Potter we're the ones meet
that was your tummy
hungee so they're ones me can't do that
either and all of a sudden like all the
previous spells or all the babies dead
people come back so like Harry's mom and
dad know I keep going keep going that's
how we're gonna get the fallen back so
it's gonna be like it's working it's
working whatever with the stones and
then like one at a time they're like
appearing like come on you've got
billions of life for me one at this time
that's three hours
Nick Fury in New York who faded away
yeah his friend was saying right next to
him yeah yeah I think at the end of day
we just don't want this to be too easy I
think that is the way they kind of if it
just seems like oh then there was no
stakes like it needs to there needs to
be more coming back we know some at
least coming back but seeing on this
topic what costs do you think that will
incur so who alive right now is the most
likely to die to lay down their life so
we consider the idea that cap Captain
America is mr. sacrifice right he's
always been kind of lay down the wire
rather than cut it and what idea is that
maybe he won't die maybe his story will
kind of go back to where it began and if
time travels gonna be part of this movie
or multiverse hopin whatever the SyFy
can see it is you know he's always had
that rain check that last dance with
Peggy Carter he's always wanted to have
and we know Peggy Carter is going to
come back to the Disney plus what-if
series she's it's gonna be her pilot
episode maybe to remind us who Peggy
Carter is she could be part of his in
the game that's one way some people talk
about stark Tony Stark you know Robert
Downey jr. might be done and maybe he'll
prove cap wrong by finally lay down the
wire sacrificing himself and maybe that
voice recording the end game trailer
that we heard will actually be his final
goodbye to pepper and it'll be found
later
and of course Thanos himself like we
don't know what the Ana's health
situation is is he mortally wounded is
he already dead are they gonna find some
corpse version of Thanos so who do you
think alive right now let's let's check
in who's at the top of your death pool
for endgame Deadpool
I love the idea of these directors
Anthony and Joe Russo and the writer is
Steven mcfreely and some Christopher
Marcus thank you uh they do a really
good job of honoring the comic accurate
version of something while also trying
to tell their story that's grounded I
like the idea that at the end of this
movie Thanos in the comics is obsessed
with death and death is like a person
like the girl I miss krysta yeah he
wants to impress her and so they can
fall in love and he can die but it's
like symbolizes that because he's
obsessed with it the idea at the end of
showing maybe a personification of death
or something that's maybe not so on the
nose but something that represents his
obsession with this idea that like you
need to kill things to make things work
like you have to make those sacrifices
it's like no you do not you you don't
need to do that this also
philosophically it doesn't make any
sense and and economically doesn't make
any sense to do something like this but
um I like the idea of doing I like a tip
of the cap to something like like
mistress death or something like that
with that I mean that actually isn't a
stretch because the whole notion of
death is that everyone has their time
and you can't mess with that it's like
they're it's their time he's wiped out
half the species he's wiped out half the
planet so it's like that if anything is
going to get death up and hot and
bothered it's gonna be like whoa you did
something that oh he's trying to play
God it interfere with faith yeah wasn't
that time it's an interesting thought
yeah and we've dealt with beings that
are like higher level and the idea of
teasing those moving for with like the
Eternals like those are kind of like
gods like space gods depending on who's
writing or whatever whatever they want
to do with that that could be a really
interesting way to end Santos's story
but at the same time I don't want to get
rid of a house I don't want to get rid
of things cuz Stannis is like that's
such a fun character you gotta have them
one more time where the heroes team up
with the villain and they go up to the
next big guy they needs to be like what
the rock was the Fast and Furious
franchise bring in the big ball dude and
like friends with them and but kind of
frenemies we don't know well let's talk
about the post-credits scenes right we
can make some specific predictions about
how this movie the end of it the
post-credits scene could set up phase 4
because the Marvel films are always
about what's coming next and we
theorized that this post-credit scene
could introduce things like black
because they could even though that this
whole movie was written and shot before
the Fox Disney merger was completed they
can shoot that stuff up to like two
weeks before the the movie gets released
it's often very simple to do that the
shawarma scene was shot like I think a
week before the first of it was gonna
yeah yeah it was shot after the premiere
they had like I think I'm like a few
weeks of yeah a few weeks in between
those so they can do some super late
so Galactus could be introduces in the
new villain of the MCU in the Infinity
Gauntlet comics he gets real pissed off
when Thanos snaps his fingers and eats a
bunch of planets and runs over with a
bunch other cosmic entities we're gonna
take you in front of the Living Tribunal
and it won't work never trust the legal
system and then maybe if the Galactus
comes in the Fantastic Four could be
introduced as the new heroes and some
have suggested that maybe the
post-credits scene will be even simpler
introducing some new characters some
random Rando who has a mutant ability in
the existence of mutant could be teased
post-credits scene bring in the x-men
and then other villains like Doctor Doom
maybe something involving Oscorp tooties
what could happen in spider-man far from
home what are you guys thinking for our
post-credit scene I like that I like
what do you think from home hey you know
what this is done
welcome to phase four it's a sight hey
let's hit the ground running yeah I
think the mr6 kind of thing maybe with
something Sarge you got hurt um I think
I have my fanboy things I want but then
like the realistic answer feels like
they would keep it the door open for
some of the characters that probably
died like if like Ironman or Captain
America goes headfirst into a wood
chipper but it's like but maybe they
made it through you know like particles
are smaller than that have come back
there you go maybe something like that
one fanboy Sam wants like silhouette
from behind like a like a dude and
you're like that's clearly a dude in
jeans and whatever he's wearing jeans
and all this thing's got fists and like
you see like three knives coming out and
then you see like or like a rocket
taking off like in like like showing
basically what we could accomplish in
the future and you see like a rocket
taking off and you see like a SUSE
really there's Johnny
storm is Ben Grimm they're going off or
maybe they finally tease like you see
daredevil walking out an iron fist -
[Laughter]
games gonna be about the finality of
certain arcs I think that post-credits
scene is gotta set up something beyond
far from home just to keep the
shareholders and fans excited for the
years to come with stuff released on
Disney Plus and what movies will be
coming next so even if it's not like an
actor appearing in a character form some
kind of tease whether it's just a logo
of Fantastic Four the way that infinity
we're in it with just a Captain Marvel
logo doesn't sound like it's that
complex to shoot they could be shooting
that right now as we speak I hope that
some they'll give us some kind of wink
at what will be in store for next I hope
so because otherwise we'll have nothing
to talk about on this channel for the
next 18 months I'm so excited I keep
looking at this poster cuz it's so cool
I'm so excited for such a personal story
with these characters as they wind down
this saga yeah me too but let's let it
snow in the comments down below what new
you're most excited for what do you
think from infinity war we should have
paid the most attention to and put in
your final bet predictions what you
think will happen but for now let's move
on to a trivia question reason thank you
guys it's our weekly trivia question I
couldn't reach the box I tried to grab
it in time you know this is when we get
a crazy trivia question which I'll try
to answer the best we can
winners get to do the outro losers get
shunned no we have a new game we used to
do a little we used to have to do
something embarrassing in front of a
green screen you can edit us into there
but now we're putting the fun I've one
of these calls they're like I don't know
mouths they're from a game openers like
what the dentist would use to make sure
that you didn't get saliva on your teeth
good call it it wedges open here huh and
then it's hard to talk with it you'll
see right out our answers make sure you
label your thing you can tell the
difference when I mean and I got a
question right here buckle up complete
this line from the poem twas the night
before Christmas what get ready I hated
our girl she did this a bundle of toys
he had flung on his back and he looked
like a blank just opening his pack
alright thank you
so much to Melissa for this beautiful
box by amazing now we're gonna yes of
course and at the end of the show we're
gonna figure out who's the winner and
who has to walk home and then we also
play around with the openers yes you
have to give up her card yep okay well
the slips a quick second to thank our
sponsor Wix Wix is a great way to make a
professional website these days it feels
like if you don't have a website you
don't exist whether you've got a small
business or a blog Wix has you covered
there's a ton of freedom in terms of
design they handle the security and
hosting side of it too we actually have
a Wix site of our own at new rockstars
if you go to new rockstars fan com
you'll find a poll where you can weigh
in on what you want us to cover on this
channel we've got a great experience
making a site we came in with something
specific they had no trouble getting it
done
and we've had no troubles with it since
get started on your own website today
for free at wix.com slash rockstars and
apply code rockstars at checkout to get
10% when upgrading to premium like it's
just seen it's like they're stars in
their eyes speaking of that we got a
final trailer for Dark Phoenix this week
that gave us some more context about
this space mission that was the segue
and showed a bit more gene grace evil
side the marketing for this movie has
some people confused about how and when
Jean Grey developed her intense powers
we saw a glimpse of them at x-men
apocalypse and but the trailer of Dark
Phoenix seems to suggest that she gets
them from a solar flare while trying to
save some astronauts so we're gonna try
to explain all of this to you very
neatly very concise usually in the
comics this is the way we've seen in
this trailer is how it goes in the
comics of course things get redcon
things get added to the past that day
but usually we see Jean Grey and the
x-men go out in space they get hit she
gets hit with the Phoenix force it's
coming towards earth and affecting some
astronauts and I oh she turns into the
Phoenix force there's a lot more comic
book gobbledygook in between but let's
go ahead and convince that right on down
why we see the Phoenix before that well
you what has been explained in comics is
that she has been marked as a powerful
mutant pretty early on in her life she
level five now level 5
hi omega-level omega-level mutant
snuggle of omega those are the highest
it's a high student graduate
Omega Omega that's not because I don't
know Charles Xavier is Omega but leading
man is an omega-level mutant yeah man
yeah he fries though he could stop time
if you wanted to because fries
anyways that's comic gobbledygook but so
far in this cuz fries but no condensing
this down so far I think what we're
seeing is her coming into her own with
these powers and having to deal with the
ramifications of her one being a kid to
possibly having her powers dampened by
Charles Xavier would seems to be teased
that he did something to Marius which is
what happened in the comics and her
maybe not being able to deal with
regular people problems anymore because
she now has the power that sometimes in
the comics is described as the power of
all life and full stop like a whole life
force throughout the universe chaotic
and it's and it's unpredictable and it
can be used for good but usually it
makes people go a wee bit crazy also
she's dealing with puberty the it seems
like correct me if I'm wrong wasn't
didn't she have a terminally ill friend
when she was like a teenager and she
tried to prevent that death from
happening and through her telepathy
powers ended up like being a blip on the
Phoenix force's radar and like oh
there's an omega-level mutant on earth
I'll put my stamp on her and we'll come
back later mark her and come back it's
interesting this trailer doesn't make it
look like there's like there aren't
anywhere near the Sun I know in the
comics there was like a solar flare and
that's how it looks like there's a
stranded NASA Space Shuttle with some
kind of weird crap floating around it
and then they go rescue it and when Jean
Grey is in there trying to help
Nightcrawler that's when this nebulous
thing attaches to her so it looks like a
solar flare so you get like a thing yeah
and then but no it's actually a thing it
seems like it could be a trap too like
the Phoenix force is trying to lure her
back out there'd be like
I'm ready to get you get off or get out
of there gonna meet me on my turf yeah
that kind of thing
yeah and I'm here we talked about the
trailer before like Jessica Chastain's
characters still unknown there's some
theories that should be playing like
another Shiar alien like big who's like
Charles Xavier wife girlfriend sometimes
whatever they wanna get confused I think
maybe she could be herself incarnation
of the Phoenix force that only Jean Grey
sees and maybe that's yeah alright let
us know what you thought about this
trailer in the comments below what
you're most looking forward to about
Dark Phoenix yes the movie is still
happening but my you were talking about
some news from the Star Wars this is my
area of expertise sorry
Sansa Phoenix so now in an interview at
Star Wars Celebration Kathleen Kennedy
dropped and exciting nugget while
talking to Josh Horowitz from MTV News
she said you know we talked about
Knights of the Old Republic all the time
yes we are developing something to look
at vague but still a glory nugget of
hope it does sound like it's projects in
very early stages it still seemed like a
good time to get into who / what the
Knights of the Old Republic ah right so
this is a very good video game that I
have told you guys to play numerous
times and I've said that it's not only
on Mac but PC those tablets you can play
it on ipad you have no excuses everyone
so what's exciting about this one it was
released on Xbox in 2003 originally it
was potato graphics it was a huge hit
it's the Old Republic is set four
thousand years before the Skywalker saga
that we have so this is like a long long
time ago in the same galaxy but it is a
long long time ago here so before the
Galactic Empire and all that stuff the
Star Wars movies have not actually
explored this time era yet but what's so
cool about this four thousand years ago
is the Jedi V versus Sith is very very
different so in the movies majority of
the time there are no Jedi there's only
sort of like the one all just the
Skywalker's and with Sith there's only
ever been like the rule of two that
we've seen in the films four thousand
years ago they were Jedi Academy there
was this school yeah you basically get
taught how to become a Jedi or a Sith
and they have armies of them on
both sides so these guys rule the galaxy
it's awesome do you go to like a
Hogwarts to learn to be good or bad yeah
I think it's like yeah if you're a
decent person you kind of follow like
the path of light but if you have the
dark side in you yeah I've actually
explored that a lot I would love to read
a young adult novel which is all about
someone who got sent to the school and
they realize that they weren't actually
that bad anyway this is why this is my
my area of expertise what are you guys
thinking about the Old Republic
we haven't actually heard if it's gonna
be a video game or if we're gonna see a
movie version of this or a television
series how do you think this narrative
version is going to come across do you
think it could be a
choose-your-own-adventure like we had
with Netflix's Bandersnatch oh yeah
Disney Plus gonna get their grubby hands
on this one - yeah grabby grabby hands
get grabbing because Mandalorian looks
as far as everyone said so far it looks
amazing beautiful cast beautiful people
honestly this sounds like the perfect
like recipe for like a magician style
like episodic series I would like to see
like what like explore every nook and
cranny of what the force can do and all
the drama that comes along with it oh
now bear with me because I get to talk
about this I want to kind of go over
these main characters here and then also
see who I think they're gonna be so
you've got HK 47 here at the Droid on
the Left who is a an assassin droid who
basically is programmed to kill and he
calls humans meatbags and so you've got
this like we saw in solo this beautiful
relationship between droids and humans
androids hating humans so fun right
there Dee got Darth Malak who's like
obviously the antagonist he's like the
big bad guy he's scary and I think he's
misunderstood then you go basilar right
here
she needs to be played by Kate
Beckinsale tomorrow oh yeah yeah because
she's actually British based on Quebec
instead
it's I won't spoil ever there's an
amazing twist in it so I would love to
see this either brought to life on the
big screen or we get another video game
even though kotor 2 wasn't as good as
the first one
yeah I hope something some adaptation
that preserves the idea of choice in it
like you mentioned the Bandersnatch
thing i Bandersnatch was a cool step
forward and a new type of storytelling
that I hadn't seen on streaming services
before I'd love to see that explored
even more in the world of Star Wars it
could be a fun thing since the morality
part of right so in order to it'd be
great to see some kind of narrative
version of that where you can have
different choices of like what you say
to that how you respond to people yeah
you know so like see if they're gonna do
something like that if they don't wanna
do another video game see a narrative
version that preserves those elements
yeah I want I would like a full series
and I want it to be why a like my dad
suggested earlier and I want all the
drama you can have a little bit of Star
Wars in there but I'm mainly main drama
riverdale and this guy asked out two
girls at the same time yeah this girl
asked out two guys at the same time just
flip it on its head one more time this
girl I stuck to droids and one of them
looks like Jar Jar whoa I'm already
signed up let me watch it now it's a
pilot episode that's respect well let us
know what version of this nice of the
Old Republic idea development idea that
you want to see whether it's a movie or
series whatever it is but Sam what has
happened in other news here's a quickie
news gang buckle up in other news the
Swamp Thing teaser dropped this week I
thought it was pretty cool and the
scandal well they suddenly shut down
production or the rumors are that they
suddenly shut down production before
they were finished shooting the show but
hey those are unconfirmed but a lot of
people reported on it so we'll figure
we'll find out more later not youth but
also there's the plagiarism claim
against the duffer brothers regarding
stranger things is heading to court next
month
yeah so what was that there was like a
short film called Montauk that early
versions of stranger things that they
pitched
they were calling the Montauk Project
and it's based off of the short film
enlike that kind of had a lot of the
same stuff that stranger things did in
the pilot but I don't know you can't
always say just because things are
similar they're the same but we don't
really know all the full details
like they doing all the way to courts
we'll see I hope everything turns out ok
but also rumors are that John Cena will
most likely play the role a peacemaker
and James Gunn's Suicide Squad reboot
the role was originally intended for
Dave Bautista cuz of course but he has
some scheduling conflicts really quick
peacemaker us is based on Charlie's a
Charleston comic character who was
bought by DC are acquired by them in the
80s and he was supposed to be in
Watchmen and when they was were based on
the Charlton characters but basically
he's comedian he's the comedian okay you
can't pace me they're pretty good you
should gift that also Shazam comes out
on DVD get your DVD players ready kids
on July 2nd and it will reportedly have
a lot of extra footage really exciting
and of course Tessa Thompson fan
favorite says she's heard a Thor 4 movie
has been pitched with Taika Waititi back
it's director I'll try to say that
quickly Thor four four four four four
yeah oh you can write it with a fourth
like with a four in the title like fan
four sloth well I guess the words okay
then you go home hey who knows them
maybe it's just Tessa Thompson but
finally we have a poster for Godzilla
king of monsters which is at least or
it's coming out very soon and for audio
listeners quick description it's picture
of Godzilla
you know big lizards surrounded by
helicopters though so to the machines
and these breathing blue flames into the
sky it's usually a nuclear dress every
morning atomic breath used tomography
blasting the crap at a fairly Hawkins
name should we read into that more inner
sting guess we'll have to wait and find
out but gang it's time for another
favorite segment of the show
lightning round you tweet us questions
that we you know put the word out on
Twitter for and we're gonna pop them up
on the screen I'm gonna fire them at my
hosts whoever has to answer them has to
do it pretty quickly no hesitation are
you guys ready yes yes hi Marco asked
for seconds how are you buddy for the
room at Curto spin off what actors would
you want to see play some of the lead
roles oh I'm so glad we do yeah yeah
yeah your bachelor kate beckinsale for
sure darth revan ah tom tom hardy oh
yeah and then we just I'm just going
from what I see on the screen HK 47 I
would it's got a good voice run in
Frayser
sure sure there you go Tim you're up
next yes a Toby one belong yeah says
does Yoda wear boxers briefs so does he
go commando he doesn't need to somewhere
I was gonna say it in backwards but but
I said it front ways first anyway it's
not he's this dude it's all natural
I need any undies when you're in the
swamp oh yeah I think actually if you
wear undies it creates well actually we
does all those flippin stuff he's gonna
need to wear something so I'm gonna go
with briefs okay this one's from at
grape Fanta for the win you guys see
there's a chance that Rey is gonna be
related to Palpatine a chance but I'm
guessing probably not not all the
characters have to be related I think
the the reveal as much of a downer as it
was in last Jedi that Rey's parents were
nobodies junk traders who just abandoned
her I'm more interested in that version
the character who is truly not connected
through any bloodline we already have
one Aegon Targaryen revealed glove line
real quick real quick if Palpatine is a
Skywalker and then Raisa Skywalker does
that meanwhile Vader's like well Anakin
turning into Vader and well oh yeah
Padme he just did the sneaky
well not everyone needs to be
Skywalker's Yanni genielle Rivera for me
said this is not quick says do you think
that Palpatine will return as a ghost
Rose essence is still around the desktop
we do know that in Canon SIF can put
their minds and mentality in old relics
in Cannon and that would be a safe idea
don't you agree no I think it's Darth
Plagueis I think that the suits have
figured out the ability to never die
under sting or visions bodies not being
used right now maybe he's an possessed
of vision you want huh Erik got one from
at was HP you ready yes please please
explain stavos to me in 15 seconds ok
Arthurian legend but a set in space a
long time ago where sun realizes that
his dad as actually as greatest villain
convinces his dad to come back to the
light and we learned the dad's backstory
and we learn about his nephew and how he
does the same thing whoa counting on my
fingers but yes laser swords and on
three we need to answer from at a pistol
Peter underscore 21 who's a bit of Jedi
Yoda obi-wan or Luke one two three think
of what the Jedi are look Luke doesn't
he abandons the Jedi Order
so did Yoda you know everyone just gets
a tan in the desert for over thirty
years
hello there and Yoda is way more flips
yeah do you think the greatest Jedi is
and thank you all for asking these
questions to us we appreciate it now
comes the time for a 15-second shout
outs where you toast as 50 tickets
shut up plug ramble about anything they
want Sam
oh well leading up to infinity wars
ending and end game start I said that
wrong anyways end games coming out and
if you want to get a quick summary you
can go to youtube.com slash might be
awesome I did a deep dive animated
explainer cartoons of what happened to
earth after everything died and guess
what gang Bad News Bears
if you were driving a car you're
probably dead so you want to learn more
go check that out and please because
it's a new project and they're very
valid they're very fragile in the
beginning South Pagal yes alright are
you gonna count me because I'm gonna get
through as much as I can in this time
and thanks to Disney Australia for
getting me premiere tickets to in game
thank you so much for Black Milk for
decking me out and some really cool
stuff especially this dress can you
check it out black male clothing calm I
also have a clothing line shop wat calm
that's my little babies to make sure
that that happens good I'm about to eat
a hundred thousand subscribers on geek
bum is at my time of you kidding me
please wear my patreon all right I'm an
counted quick sorry I was just counting
one two three four I was an accurate
seconds for me May 3rd the week after
in-game will be my next darkest timeline
comedy at the Acme theatre North
Hollywood look out on my social media
for all the details on that that's what
sold out this is so excited to hopefully
everyone will so if you missed it here's
a chance if you ever visiting in town
tried to make it on the first Friday of
the month see and come hang out with us
now we return to retrieve a question we
asked earlier we punishment box set up
here and then go and spread those that
will go over I'll read the question one
more time because we definitely had to
read it a couple times because I've
already forgot what it was Charles
Dickens yes of course here it goes
ok best answer mod we'll start with your
answer complete this line of the poem
twas the night before Christmas a bundle
of toys he had flung on his back and he
looked like a blank just opening his
pack so here I'm gonna read it again and
then you enter to answer a bundle of
toys he had flung on his back and he
looked like a gem says rat just opening
his pack
yes a bundle of toys he had flung on his
back and he looked like a snack just
opening his bag that's pretty good some
internal Rhymes and finally Eric wrote a
bundle of toys he had flung on his back
and he looked like a the screaming
hoarder on the corner of Lankershim and
Moorpark just opening his pack pretty
sure that's it he's got a big pack all
right he might not be I might not be far
off because our answer is a bundle of
toys he had flung on his back and he
looked like a peddler just opening the
door
what a headless have usually snacks no
he looked like a snack he looks
delicious that's what I'm trying to say
he looks like a I mean one Vic which
one's the most wrong all right so the
judges have voted buckle up kids cuz
it's a shocker
no it's not Derek lost it sorry Derek
lost and my last one so cuz everyone
knows that Santa's [ __ ] if you put your
mind to it
he's skylights I want to read our
goodbyes with ya and mod you get to
humiliate him there you go you have a
very little math but continue but I hate
it because it looks like someone behind
you is saying your words for you
[Applause]
[Music]
you can actually leave directly rock
stars like this video podcast can
subscribe to the actor desire and I'll
see you next a podcast hard say your
last name
[Laughter]
[Music]